over 94% of the EU budget goes straight
back to its citizens to regions cities
farmers businesses and young people a
majority of the budget comes from member
state contributions
the rest is drawn from customs and
agricultural duties and a percentage of
v18 but Parliament says is not enough to
match the --use ambitions and to face
new challenges like migration security
and climate change the gender in
European varicosity it will never been
the proper MEP stress that EU taxpayers
should not have to pay more the EU needs
to find new own resources among
Parliament's proposals are a financial
transaction tax a digital sector tax and
a share of corporate tax revenue or
environmental taxes new own resources
could mean a reduction in the direct
contributions you countries make to the
budget business Victim Witness Adana
Rajesh's of obsidian negotiated far with
VIPRE Abu Hamza stylish missions in a
hostile person of Cusco tiene su des
portes abner del Kavala politics na
remote official ahead
[Music]
you